[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dites-moi
tout ce que je veux juste vous dire Je
ne vous ferai aucun
mal Je veux juste connaître vos
différentes vies ici
les gens J'ai entendu dire que certains d'entre vous ont des familles
vivant dans des cages  grands et
froids, certains restent assis là et dépoussièrent au-
delà de l'âge de la
vieillesse, mais est-ce
vrai, s'il vous plaît, laissez-moi
vous parler, je veux juste connaître les pièces derrière
votre
esprit ou est-ce que je vois un vide là-bas ou est-ce que je
deviens
aveugle ou est-ce  reste juste un VI qui
s'est produit il y
a longtemps des choses comme aimer le
monde et laisser libre cours à ta fantaisie
est-ce
vrai s'il te plaît laisse-moi te parler
est-ce vrai
je veux juste
te parler j'avais vécu ici
avant l'époque des
yeux alors bien sûr  c'est pourquoi je suis si
préoccupé par la
Terre parce que je suis revenu pour
trouver les étoiles de cet
endroit et l'odeur du monde qui est
[Musique]
brûle l'odeur d'un monde qui est
brûle